what did you think when you first saw
Mike tyon well I I want to I want to see
his birth certificate because he 190 lbs
12 years old and all solid yeah um you
know really but yeah just physically
just as a physical specimen and and big
guy yeah and
listen cuz was right I was a teacher he
was right and he was testing me even
that day he said what do you think so I
said well we ain't going to know nothing
in the bag who the freak cares about
that he knocked the bag down we got to
put him in with uh we got no one to put
them in that way I didn't have anyone
that way we got to test them everyone's
got to be tested and um so you got to
put them in responsibly but let's put
him in just respons but let's put him in
with Bobby Stewart former Prof figh had
14 Prof fights smaller than Tyson uh he
was when he was fighting he was 175 but
still he's 28 years old Tyson's 12 come
on
and and he'll work with him right so we
do we put him Tyson he recognized the
moment he understood this was an
audition this was a chance you know this
was that TV show change your life and he
understood that if he passed the
audition he could change possibly change
his life he wasn't sure what how could
he be sure what exactly but it was
better than what he had and so he was on
aition so he wanted he and L understood
what we would want to see ferociousness
toughness uh character uh desire you
know and of course ability well we saw
the ability power speed but it was it
was unbridled it was untaught it was it
was raw he didn't know really much at
all um at all but we saw that but he
wanted to show more he knew that wasn't
enough again a Nate intelligence
he he had to show desire he had to show
toughness and so I was being responsible
after two rounds that's enough normally
I don't put a guy into boxing until
maybe four months five months 6 months
eight months 10 it depends what it takes
to learn on the floor before it's
responsible to put him in the ring to to
actually take on uh incoming real live
shells instead of blanks yeah and so
normally I wouldn't have in and I knew
after today he wouldn't be in the ring
again if I trained him I would teach him
first and then he'd get back in in a few
months but for this day it was the only
way it's kind of like I used to make
this analogy and C loved it I he said
what's traded a fighter what do you what
do you look for trading a fighter Teddy
you know he asked me this ridiculous
question just to test me and and I say
it's like going to Macy's with he loved
it I said it's like I said it's like go
to Macy's window Chris he goes what do
you mean Macy's window you know CU was
like boom boom boom so what do you mean
Macy's window well you go to Macy's
window and they get the window with
everything you want to see everything in
there it looks great oh everything and
yeah and then what well then you ask
what's in the warehouse and they tell
you
nothing yeah and and cuz says that's it
that's a trainer yeah and I wanted to
see what was in the
warehouse because I saw what was in a
Macy's window I saw the power I saw the
speed so he goes to round
and he gets a bloody nose here's the
weird thing not weird very telling we
knew what we were doing not bragging but
we knew what we were doing because he
got a bloody nose because he got
hit after that Bloody he never got
another bloody nose you know why he
didn't get hit cuz he learned he was
still strong but he was smarter now
anyway he goes two rounds and I saw and
I'm being responsible because if he goes
more it's not responsible I saw what I
needed to say I saw speed I saw power I
saw athleticism and I saw I didn't
believe him I thought he was lying to me
I'm just telling you I I thought he was
lying trying to act tough when he wasn't
really feeling tough it didn't matter
cuz questioned me on it afterwards what
did you say and when I said he goes
young Master you know again he wasn't
paying me money so he had to give me
something right and and that was better
than that was currency young master I'm
young Master whoa you know young Master
you know what I mean I felt like that
guy Kung Fu you know like in the movie
like Kung F grasshopper when you're
ready when you could take this out of my
hand you can to leave and that's
powerful yeah it was it worked cuz knew
how to work me and he did and and it
worked and and so but you know what I
didn't mind being worked I kind of knew
I was being shuffled a little bit well
you're making it sound a little bit
negative but it's also extremely
positive that's a teacher instilling
wisdom into you that you carried forward
and impacted a lot of people yeah cuz
got the job done but he did it his way
and and he did for a lot of a myriad of
reasons and but at the end of the day it
was all good and I I just had to
understand that eventually uh later on
but and you do the same you do things
your way and carry some of him in you
some of your father in you yeah that day
you know that day was funny because when
C said what did you see Teddy when him
well after two rounds I got up in the
ring I knew I was going to train him
obviously we weren't going to say no and
he still had about four months to serve
and we were going to work it out yeah
and when I got up on a ring apron that's
my gym I'm the boss you know people
later on in life called me a dictator
you know what I said yeah you're right I
didn't deny people thought you you you
mean I'm right yeah I'm a dictator I'm a
trainer I'm the boss I'm in charge if I
you wouldn't be here if I wasn't what
the freak you need me for if I'm not
freaking in charge you idiot yeah yeah
damn right what do you think it's a it's
a Shar responsibility no it's my
responsibility that's why you're here
yeah I am in charge and you shouldn't be
here if you don't understand that so I
get up there and I know that I'm going
to be training them I got to show them
who the boss is you know I'm being
really Frank about this so I get up
there say that's it out yeah no no you
know this Ty no let me go I want to do
another round I want to do another I
want I said out did you hear what I said
because I knew that you know he was
going to test me he was testing me I I
said I said get
out he got out but were you impressed
with the fact that you want to keep
going or no yes and I recognized what it
really was so C asked me what was that
cuz want to know what the young Master
saw so God said what was that M I said
it was um
it was an act he goes you saw
that did he really want to go I said no
I said he didn't really want to go but
he knew that we want him to go and he
made himself ready to go in order to
satisfy and that's just as good and C
said damn right it's just as good all
that matters was not not not how he got
there but that he got there that's all
that matters that he got there that he
got to place to act like a fighter to to
do what we want him to do to be ready to
persevere to go beyond the Comfort level
to do another round he didn't want to
damn righty didn't want to but he knew
we want him to and he knew in order to
pass the test he had to do it and he
said you're right he goes now it's going
to be your job to teach him to make him
a fighter that don't get bloody noses
that don't get get hit and will get to
that place without being
coerced to get there to get to that
place on his
own instead of using the things that he
had to use to get to that place today
those things are not going to be
available one day when you and listen to
this you talk about a man being
prophetic CU was pretty good you talk
about man being on a job on a money Lex
he says how do you think he finishes the
sentence he goes because someday you
because you know you're going to have to
make sure that he lears these things
because you know he he'll be your first
heavyweight
chip what did you just say he's 12 years
old yeah yeah he he's been arrested 30
times he's getting out of jail out of
you know Juvenile Detention frion
um he's a mess in a lot of ways there's
a lot of things we find out later a lot
of problems weaknesses so he goes and
you that's part of your job that'll be
part of your job and but he really said
that he and then then he turned to him
he goes you want to come live with us
young man you want to be your
fighter yes even that CZ said to me
later what do you think about that I
said he a the way he said yes yeah the
way he said yes yes sir yeah he said
what do you think about that and we're
talking I said ain't going to be that
light in a little while down the road
again he knew that that's what he felt
that he needed to to project himself out
to to present himself at to to get to
where he wanted to get to he go you yeah
yeah did you see what C was seeing in
terms of the heavyweight champion of the
world no again be easiest answer would
be yes Teddy Teddy Al genius wow wow
Teddy wow no no no no but again it was
my job job yeah and I just I my job was
simple simpler than cusses cus Knew Too
Much I knew nothing I just knew you know
rudiments of boxing I knew what it took
to be a fighter and and how to execute
it the steps of executing it so I took
those steps the the the rest of it you
get blurred by those other things I
wasn't blurred by those other things I
it was it was just get him in the
gym make him mentally stronger make him
face things and teach them how to slip
punches and and create holes and fill
those freaking holes with devastating
punches this C and what are you going to
do I'm going to teach him to fill holes
and fill them with punches with bad
intentions yeah and and that became the
Monica yeah and then Tyson would say
that I'm throwing punches with bad
intentions yes you are and um you
know
that